hi everybody we're in the Toyota green
room here at CBS News I'm Peter
Greenberg the travel editor of CBS News
for another edition of Facebook live I'm
joined by Southwest CEO and chairman
Gary Kelly Gary thanks for coming in
it's great to be here Peter I mean the
word that is operative in all of our
vocabularies these days is disruption
you guys have been disrupting since 1972
but there's been so much disruption with
political events economic events natural
disasters I mean what do you see coming
up that you couldn't even anticipate
anymore as an airline well there's
always the unanticipated do you think
about the storms that we had the
hurricanes we've had fires we've had you
know earthquakes so we always have to be
ready in my opinion in our business for
the unexpected but except for the
unexpected you know we're doing really
well right now
should that be your motto except for the
unexpected well you know it sometimes
there are anticipated disruptive things
and right now everything's running
pretty smooth and when we talk about
pretty smooth every airline now is
making a profit but you've actually
reported profits for more than forty
four years which in the airline business
is unheard of I go back to the Richard
Branson quote if you want to be a
millionaire if you know start with an
airline with a billion dollars and you
will quickly become a millionaire
exactly yeah these are really good times
you know we're enjoying very low energy
prices demand is very good the economic
expansion is continuing we're hopeful
that we'll have tax reform that will
certainly help the transportation
industry and Airlines in particular well
let's talk about tax reform because
right now the corporate tax drop is
estimated to be about 21 percent under
the current bill it may be around 2022
somewhere in that not a lot of CEOs are
saying or at least volunteering that
they're going to reinvest that in their
employees and their product create new
jobs go from the c-suite Suites of Main
Street you're one of those who says
we're going to do that absolutely we're
growing airline we have a lot of
opportunities to grow this will put us
in an even better position to grow and
in addition to investing in airplanes
and more jobs
it just gives us an opportunity to share
with our existing employees and and also
with our shareholders so it puts us on a
more level playing field with other
industries with respect to our cost to
cap
is a very necessary and welcome change
well two of the secrets to your success
ones operational and one is just dealing
with customers on the operational side
you're only operating one kind of plane
the 737 that since day one right which
means you can try it you can cross
training just about everybody to operate
one piece of equipment your spare parts
inventory is just subsidized it just
really is focused on that and then from
the consumer perspective you've branded
your entire airline as not charging for
check bags but everybody else is you're
not charging for change fees so nobody's
going to their wallet well it's just
part of our purpose we we exist to
connect people to what's important in
their lives with friendly reliable and
low-cost air travel so we do as many
things as possible to be efficient keep
our costs low shall we can share those
savings with our customers and be
America's low fare leader but at the
same time my devil's advocacy question
is you're leaving a lot of money on the
table by not charging for those check
bags if you look at the reports of every
other airline you're not an American
Delta and some of the other competitors
on the low fare categories a huge part
of their revenue is coming from
ancillary fees like check bags and
change fees well you've already pointed
out our profitability record you know
not only are we unprecedented in the
airline industry but I'll bet you won't
find many US corporations that have been
profitable for forty four consecutive
years so our business model works but
our whole theory is we want to be again
friendly reliable and low-cost it's the
friendly part we don't want to surprise
our customers with hidden fees and our
theory is that we'll gain more loyalty
get more customers because they know
that they're going to be able to trust
Southwest to get a low fare and great
service you started as a point-to-point
carrier within the state of Texas back
in 1972 you were on that one of those
first flights with two people on it
right did you ever think in a million
years that a you'd be flying
internationally well actually we started
in 1971 and you're right you and I flew
in 1972 not together but yeah I've been
the other guy in the plane yes and you
know I you know in the time I was a high
school kid and I thought man this
company is never gonna make it but I was
wrong you know and it just shows the
power of low
because when people travel they want to
have money in their pocket to spend when
they get to their destination but it's
also its Southwest great service so
we've become the largest airline in the
United States was four thousand
departures today with almost with with
over four thousand daily departures many
times of the year and it just puts us in
a great position with that many
customers to continue to expand our
route map we have very loyal fans we add
a new destination they say great now I
can fly my favorite airline to the
Caribbean or to Mexico and soon to
Hawaii well let's talk about Hawaii
because there's something called the
Southwest effect I've seen it many in
many markets in the United States the
University of Virginia did a study on it
and they looked at all the metrics and
came up with an actual hard conclusion
that anytime Southwest enters a new
market fares drop so the big bad
question about Hawaii is you're gonna go
to Hawaii in 2018 are you gonna predict
that the fares are gonna drop absolutely
but again you think about any company if
they're going to expand they have to
believe they have a competitive
advantage they're bringing something
better to the marketplace and for us
it's going to be lower fares but on top
of that is going to be great service by
but our wonderful employees now we're
sitting here talking about your route
network at a time when there are so many
airports the United States that would
make the claim they're being underserved
we're the legacy carriers of either
pulled out or have never gone and I
would assume sitting at your desk in
your chair every day there's somebody
some may are knocking on your door
begging you to fly to that city to save
them that's true that is true and we're
very grateful for that I mean we how
many of you actually added we relish the
opportunity we were the fact that we're
just wanted so I think the most recent
example is Cincinnati Ohio after all
these years and they love having
Southwest and we love being a part of
that community so I think the way to
think about Southwest is we have about a
hundred destinations that we serve today
right now we believe there are 50 more
destinations that are eligible with 737
service all based on your model based on
our model in North America including
Hawaii including Canada
as example so I think that'll keep us
busy for the next generation and the
thing is of all I mean just to put this
in perspective of all the people
knocking on your door how many actual
new routes have you added in the last
three years
well we've expanded probably close to 20
percent over the last three years maybe
not quite that much 15 to 20 percent a
lot of that international now a lot of
that international I think we've grown
our route map by about 10 destinations
over that time period so the rule of
thumb for me is I'd like to be able to
add 2 to 3 new cities a year and first
though take care of the markets that
we're currently serving so when our
flights get full we know it's time to
add more flights and it may not be real
sexy in terms of new destinations but
it's just important to make sure that we
take care of our existing customers but
about new routes it's not just about
dipping your toe in the water and your
case it's once you're in your and you
you actually jump in and stand yeah I
think in that regard we're very
different than a lot of our competitors
we don't go into a market as an
experiment we make a commitment we said
we're going to Cincinnati we're going to
make that work they can count on us
being there for them over but Cincinnati
was a perfect storm for you I mean
here's an airport that used to have 900
daily departures were down to 170 when
Delta closed Comair so they were being
underserved look what they are on the
map right and you could go in there with
low fares the Southwest affected and
it's a win-win and that's what we look
for underserved and overpriced whether
it's a city pair or a city but yeah
there's a city motto for you underserved
and overpriced you know it works
yeah passenger hat now what's the one
thing that you actually hate about your
own airline that you want to change I
don't think there's anything I hate
about it's the love air law stop it stop
it come on give me one well a passenger
I just think that there is wonderful
opportunities with in the digital age
that we live with all the devices that
people have access to employees and
customers to get better information to
them faster get the right information at
the right time
and obviously it has to be accurate so I
think that's really the next wave of
customer experience improvement I mean
in the service industry it's not the
delivery of the service that usually
makes a difference it's how you recover
well that's certainly the case you know
we cancel very few flights but it you
know it'll be thousands of flights in a
year and then react AMA dating those
customers and getting them where they
want to go becomes very important and
sometimes we have the same challenge
with our own people with our own flight
crews so getting them where they need to
be so there's definitely opportunities
there as well well speaking of that we
all saw and if we didn't see it once we
probably saw it five times all the
videos of the United Airlines incident
in Chicago and other incidents in in
Hawaii and at all three of the other
airlines that you compete with the major
airlines and most of it involved over
booking or people being people being
literally pulled off flights because
wasn't had a valid seat what lessons did
you learn from that well you know first
of all we just review our own policies
and procedures to make sure that they're
sensible and to make sure that they're
being followed and practiced there's
always you know every situation can be a
little bit different we want to empower
our people to make good judgments and
make good decisions but the main thing
that we chose to do is to stop the
practice of overbooking and I think
that's been a very good decision so
right now JetBlue doesn't do it and you
don't do it that's right and is it
working
oh yeah the results have been fantastic
the number of over the number of denied
boardings that result from an over
booking is down 75% so it's having the
desired effect and we have full
airplanes your boarding process used to
be a cattle call now it's like a second
grade fire drill or it has to stand in
their designated line I never thought
that was going to work and even
sometimes I'm in the C group I got to
tell you what it works I think it works
very well it just it allows our
customers to relax when they're in the
the gate area and not be queued up for
an excessive amount of time I think it's
the best boarding process in the
industry we get a lot of very positive
feedback on that we've been doing it for
ten years now which is kind of hard
to believe but it works for us our
customers
the vast majority prefer the open
seating model and it's just a way to
organize that boarding process better
last question on definition of terms
about what an airline is I remember that
when Freddie Laker put in a first-class
section he failed when MGM which was an
all first-class airline put in a coach
section they failed you're all coach any
ideas about putting in a first-class
concession for some of us who like the
upgrade there's no second class on
Southwest so you said that before it's
no our customers like it we like it it
works with our open seating model I
think we all cherish the efficiency that
Southwest Airlines brings our airplanes
are on the ground very very long and
that puts them in the air and keeps our
costs down so it works customers favor
Southwest in terms of the brand research
that we do over many companies for that
matter but certainly over most of the
airlines so I think we've got a good
thing going and we don't want to mess it
up so the real upgrade is just being in
boarding Group a yeah you know and so
there there is an advantage in people's
minds to when they board the aircraft
and yeah we we brand that accordingly
and you're not going to go back and ever
charge for bags well I'd never say never
however there is absolutely no thought
whatsoever that we would begin to charge
for bags and I love the position that
Southwest has of transparency and we
don't nickel and dime our customers
that's what customers want they want to
get good value out of their fare and
that's what they get with Southwest Gary
Kelly CEO Southwest Airlines
thanks so much from the Toyota green
room back to you guys